[music playing]
TIM SAMUELS: If turning
the clock back to the 1950s
wasn't far enough for
me and my cushion tush,
I have a date with
another popular school.
One that draws its inspiration
from caveman times.
Valentina Vychushanina's
class encourages men and women
to tap into their
primordial instincts
by summoning up the
inner Flintstone.
[russian speech]
You are strong.
I am with you.
And I am believing you
are powerful every time,
and you are my king and the
most powerful man in my life.
And I know you are.
That's unbelievable.
I need that as my ring tone.
Can you-- can you record
this for me later?
I need to listen to
this every morning.
I need to wake up to this.
Deep inside, woken
from a slumber
of Western egalitarianism,
my inner Fred Flintstone
began to stir.
[speaking russian]
[roars]
A wild beast?
Yeah.
Oh, OK. [growls]
Wow.
Like an epic 007 fight scene.
A British hero fends off the
Russian villain from reaching
the beautiful woman.
Eh, maybe more Mr. Bean.
Darling.
I kept him away from you.
[growls] This is-- it's
like being a caveman again.
Yeah, yeah.
Exactly.
Because it's nature of
power inside of your body.
Yes.
It's always there.
How do you feel?
I feel like a new man.
And how do you feel?
I like when you feel
the strong inside of you,
and you become more--
Manly.
--strong man.
Yes.
I like it.
You like it.
Yeah.
So should we get married?
Yeah?
That's what the
course is, isn't it?
And what could be more
manly than draping
an awkward arm around a
girl, who it turns out,
already had a boyfriend.